[Music]
morning everyone it's boris johnson's
much heralded freedom day in
england as lockdown restrictions are
lifted but the pm and his chancellor
will spend it in isolation
after coming into contact with the
health secretary who has covered
of course we know the pair hadn't
initially planned to stay at home but
were
forced into an embarrassing u-turn any
euphoria mr johnson might have hoped for
is being overshadowed by anger
at the so-called pandemic with 1.7
million people self-isolating after
being contacted
by the nhs app or by test and trace
our chief political correspondent john
craig reports
may be worse places to self-isolate than
checkers
the prime minister's 16th century grace
and favor mansion in the chiltons
but this is not where boris johnson
wanted to spend so-called freedom day
as lockdown rules in england are finally
eased
and yet after admitting he and rishi
sunak did look
briefly at avoiding isolation and
despite a humiliating u-turn
the pm is now urging the public to
follow the rules
and be cautious i know how frustrated
all this but i really do urge
everybody to stick with the program
and take the appropriate course of
action when you're asked
to do say do so by nhs test and trace
coinciding with the pm starting his
isolation
the government has announced that
frontline health workers are to be
spared
self-isolation rules in a move to tackle
the so-called ping demick
from today fully vaccinated nhs and
social care staff
identified as a close contact of a case
of covid19
by nhs test and trace will be able to
carry on working
after a negative pcr test and daily
negative lateral flow tests but while
this move will be widely welcomed
the labour leader says too many
restrictions are being lifted today
we can already see that the infection
rates are going through the roof
we know what's going to happen with
hundreds of thousands of people being
asked to
self-isolate the prime minister is
essentially putting the whole nation
into a car pressing accelerator and
taking the seat belt
off but senior conservatives are calling
on the health secretary sajid javid
who tested positive on saturday
triggering the pm and the chancellor's
isolation
to bring forward from august the 16th
the date when
all double-jabbed people will be able to
escape
isolation after a negative pcr test
and end the pindemic john craig sky news
well i'm pleased to be able to tell you
that the vaccines minister nadim zahawi
is joining us this morning mr zaharweek
many congratulations uh
on the vaccine row light it seems to be
going great guns
freedom day today is what we've been
told are you veering more towards
uh elation or trepidation
for the days and weeks ahead i think
look
throughout this um pandemic we have
faced different challenges
and the vaccination program has
demonstrated
this country's ability to rise to that
challenge incredible coming together the
nhs our armed forces local government
the private sector 80 000 vaccinated
volunteers came out of retirement
ba staff joining the vaccinated
army and of course uh many many hundreds
of thousands others who volunteered to
usher people through the vaccination
centers we all want to return to
normality
this is a a virus that is highly
infectious
respiratory disease virus aerosol
transmitted so we have to be careful we
have to remain vigilant
our border controls remain in place our
expectation and recommendation that
people in crowded places
continue to wear masks and take both
personal
and corporate responsibility in doing so
and it's great to see tfl
and others doing that so it is step
four it's an important step uh there is
no perfect time to take this step
this is as good a time as any as chris
whittie has said with the summer
holidays and schools being out which
will hopefully
bear down on the r number the
transmission rate
so i'm confident that we're doing the
right thing almost
88 just shy of that 87
uh i have now had the protection of one
dose and
68 of all adults have the protection of
two doses
so um i think the vaccination program
has allowed us
to take this step take it cautiously
with this wall of protection
of adults in the united kingdom okay
that was a very long answer wasn't it to
my question i'm not sure you answered it
though elation or trepidation for the
weeks
ahead um cautious optimism is probably
the way i would describe it
um i hope that helps uh kate that's a
shorter answer
uh uh and i hope we can leave it at that
before you get before you go any further
you talked about masks uh we heard
prince charles saying he doesn't want to
wear a mask and camilla's not going to
wear a mask are you going to wear a mask
so i will wear a mask in crowded
indoor spaces i will wear a mask if i'm
on a
train carriage that is crowded because
not only will it
obviously protect myself but it'll
protect others around me i don't know if
someone sitting next to me
is immunosuppressed or you know
compromised
and to put them at risk unnecessarily
with a virus that i know transmits very
very
effectively through aerosol transmission
it's a respiratory disease
highly transmissible so i would
absolutely wear a mask in crowded places
okay so so the future king is wrong then
to say that he doesn't want to wear a
mask
no i think look um the guidance are
clear
in indoor crowded places it's the right
thing to do is to wear masks and it's
recommended
and we are asking people to take
responsibility and
of course organizations whether it's tfl
or others to take corporate
responsibility uh
the supermarkets have come out around
how they want
their customers to behave in the
supermarkets this is important
you know we all want to go back to
normal but part of going back to normal
is having to deal with some of these
difficult situations and i think it's
right that
individuals and corporations and
public institutions do that and think it
through
by doing the right thing we've got to
control uh and
transition this virus from pandemic to
endemic
as i think we will begin to do so with a
booster campaign in this in september as
well which we can talk more about
questions should we we've got lots to
get through including this pesky
pandemic
1.7 million people are presently
self-isolating you are looking at trying
to change that
for some people who work for the nhs
explain that to me simply if you will
because i was reading it this morning
it's a bit complicated
yeah no absolutely okay so for nhs
frontline and social care staff
who have had the alert if they are
double vaccinated
then they can work with their employer
to take a pcr test and if they are
negative then they can go back to work
without having to self-isolate being
careful being precautionary
not being close to people who are
extremely vulnerable
to the virus but this will allow the nhs
and social care
to cope as we of course transition this
virus as i say from
from pandemic status to endemic status
so it's
the additional way of helping the nhs uh
and social care to do that for those
staff who are double vaccinated from
when
so we've announced it today um so it
begins um
immediately uh for them to to to begin
to
be able to if they are double vaccinated
go back to work without having
to ice it of course they have to take a
pcr test and that has to be negative if
it's positive
they have to obviously then uh uh uh
isolate for that 10-day period yeah what
about people who work in supermarkets or
people who work in factories because
we've heard from people like marx and
spencer sainsbury's
iceland they've they said that they're
on the knees and they don't have enough
staff working
factories are the same making our cars
etc are you going to have exemptions for
other key workers as well
so i just want to say to obviously key
workers and
businesses small medium and large is
that it is difficult
this is hard this is not a normal year
and the
uh nhs app has proven its worth saving
tens of thousands of lives hundreds of
thousands of people identified and asked
it
to isolate it's an important clinical
piece of advice to people
who come into contact with someone who
has then tested
positive so it's important that we work
together
to try and get to the hopefully the 16th
of august when actually if you're double
vaccinated
you don't need to self-isolate and that
will also help businesses further
the reason for the for the for the gap
bring the exemptions forward are you
going to
have exemptions for others as well as or
is it just going to be
for the nhs until the 16th of august so
at the moment it's for the nhs
and for social care staff these are
important uh
clinical care is incredibly important at
this uh
any time i would suggest uh but the 16th
of august
is all so for the rest of the economy
the reason for
the the gap is to allow more people to
be protected
with two doses we we aim to
get everyone protected but with two
doses by the middle of
september if they've taken the dose
we've now met the target of offering the
vaccine to every adult
uh uh you know head of the 19th uh today
i think you've had three weeks this
morning i can't get a word in edgeways
uh tell me about the fact that by the
16th of august we might not have any
food
on our shelves in the supermarkets if
this app keeps pinging away
why won't you look at other sectors as
well well as i said
it's important that we protect the
nhs and social care because they're
offering protection to the most
vulnerable people in our society
don't we minister i don't disagree with
you all i'm all i'm saying is
actually it's important that we work
together i think
businesses are rising to the challenge
many of them i know my colleagues
in the business department have been
talking to for example the
hospitality sector the entertainment
sector who are opening up
uh as of today where we're working with
them to make sure that they use the
app and by the way it's really worth
noting that since the 17th of may
okay when we develop the app uh pass
for the uh certification um six million
people have actually downloaded
the app in last month two and a half
million people and they're not just
using it
for the covered bit they're using it to
order their uh
uh prescriptions over order and of
course
gp appointments the chancellor when we
have story to interrupt we've only got a
little
bit of time left when we had the
chancellor uh in the back of our cab
last
week he said that you're going to be
looking at the sensitivity of the app
are you so when the app was developed it
was developed in a world with no
vaccines
at all we're now as i said almost at 88
of all adults having
the vaccine we review the app all the
time i think the important thing is that
the
clinical advice to people if you've come
into contact with someone with covert
remains our priority through the app
that's the right thing to do
and then of course to make sure that we
continue to review the
the quality of that detection radar
system
all the time but we take nothing for
granted what i don't understand
minister is what you can do to change
the app because you know the app says if
you are within
two meters of somebody for uh 15 minutes
then you're going to have to
self-isolate if they then suddenly
find themselves sadly with covid at home
so how can you actually change it how
can you change the sensitivity of it
no so what i'm trying to say to you is
is i think the right thing to do
is to continue to clinically advise
people
with that sensitivity that they have
come into contact with people
who have tested positive the difference
now
is that we've got almost 88 people with
one dose
and 68 of people with two doses
so we can take decisions like we've just
done um with the nhs and social care
staff
we can make decisions that on the 16th
of august
anyone who's double vaccinated doesn't
need to then
isolate if they are pinged and if they
don't test positive
for covert so those changes are
happening because of the vaccination
program
yeah um you were looking at vaccinating
some kids
why not all of them they're pesky little
super spreaders aren't they
so the joint committee on vaccination
and immunization
have just delivered their advice we'll
consider it in fact
uh after my morning round uh we have a
covedo and then i will make a statement
to parliament
but suffice to say they've looked very
closely especially at children
who are more vulnerable to serious
infection from covert
children who live with adults who are
more vulnerable serious infection from
covert and of course 17 year olds who
are close to
becoming 18 so three months from the
18th birthday and we will
uh take that advice on board and i'll
make a statement to parliament later
today
and why not all the kids as i was saying
why not all children
so the jcbi are continuing to review
that
there's now emerging data of children
all children being vaccinated in america
and elsewhere with the first dose
not yet enough data with a second dose
so they want to look at
all the data there is a very rare signal
around something called myocarditis
which is an inflammation of the heart
uh and on balance um i think the jcbi
are coming down on the side of
continuing to review all children
healthy children
but actually wanting to protect the
vulnerable children first okay just
before i let you go
on my way to work this morning about
quarter to four there were an awful lot
of very relaxed young people
in central london um celebrating after
the clubs opened
at midnight last night when was the last
time you went to a club
oh my goodness what was the last time i
went to club probably
a couple of years ago um on holiday
uh but um the important did you go
stop it um
so karaoke bar or something no
no it was a it was it was it was a good
club it was actually uh
a club and i think it was in dubai but
pretty pretty
um uh impressive uh but nevertheless
sounds very racy for a minister of uh
the government
anyway the important thing okay is that
we're working
with nightclub operators uh to use
the uh covert app um both for testing
and of course uh those who are
vaccinated so that we continue to safely
enjoy
uh at night clubbing in the united
kingdom the important thing is the
businesses
and i know my business colleagues uh are
doing that paul scully's doing that
with the section at the moment well i
know a few clubs in london next time mrs
said is out of town
give me a ring and i'll i'll show you a
good time minister it's good to talk to
you thanks for joining us on the program
this morning
you're on okay it's a deal
don't get that on the other channels j
is still to come on the program for you
this morning as
england eases lockdown restrictions
we'll discuss the rising number of new
cases of coronavirus with
dr david nabarro from the world health
organization that's at half past
seven from today double vaccinated nhs
and care staff in england will be
allowed to avoid self-isolation we'll
talk to the shadow health secretary john
ashworth
at five past eight and we'll find out
how
senior scientists view today's decision
to ease lockdown restrictions
in england professor andrew hayward he's
a member
of the sage committee will be with us at
8 20.
so from today the lockdown is all but
over in england nightclubs are open as
we were saying and there's no limit
on the number of people who can attend
weddings and funerals
restrictions are also being eased in
scotland
let's just remind you what's changing
and what's staying the same here we go
you'll be able to go to a club or a
non-distance concert
have however many guests you want at an
event and order a pint at the bar
but the government still wants people to
be cautious it says people should still
wear a mask in some settings it's also
calling for people
to limit some social contacts and to
check in at events
or pubs and you will still have to
isolate if you test positive or are
contact
traced while quarantined for travelers
from redless countries
is staying in place either bennett
reports
they are restrictions we have all got
used to but after 16 long months
in england they are legally no more
social distancing
can be distanced masks are now optional
but still required in some places
lockdown
technically speaking is unlocked
fantastic you know i mean it's just
freedom again you can't keep life on
pause
forever at some point you've got to find
a balance we've just got to get on with
it it's never going to be a good time
really hey one two three
but it is undoubtedly a good time for
cultural venues like london's royal
albert hall
which will reopen tonight with a full
capacity for the first time since
march last year for concert halls like
this this moment couldn't have come
soon enough audiences are essential for
both the performance
and the finances but when this place is
full again
with more than 5 000 people inside it
will probably feel
very strange indeed it's going to be
strange to observe
strange to be in the audience strange to
be on stage and i think
very emotional for our staff our
stewards our crew
all the performers and the audience
we've not been in this situation for so
long it's going to be
very i think exciting exhilarating and
odd all at the same time all adults have
now been offered a first dose of a
vaccine but there are still those who
are classed as vulnerable who aren't
fully protected
campaigners say the vast majority of
pregnant women are yet to have two
jabs the government has ignored pregnant
women throughout this pandemic
sadly we have seen at every stage of the
guidance and every stage
of policy making that pregnant women
have just been a
completely forgotten cohort and their
levels of anxiety
are terrifying there's unease too among
some scientists with fears the soaring
cases
could translate into debts if people
remain
cautious um then the numbers of deaths
that we see
maybe in the region of 30 or 40 000
deaths in the next year
but this could be many many more if um
people go back to
near the sorts of behaviors that we have
before the pandemic in terms of nixon
the government is urging caution as it
dispenses with the rules
affording freedoms but not in the way it
had hoped
either bennett sky news
well our business correspondent paul
kelso is at didcot
parkway station in oxfordshire traveling
into london
and becky johnson is at birmingham new
street station for us this morning hello
to you both lovely to see you becky to
you first of all what's it looking like
[Applause]
well you know it's really interesting
this train just about to depart to
nottingham this morning
nowhere near full you know considering
that people can return to work from
today
we're seeing nothing like the kind of
numbers of people at birmingham new
street station
that you would have seen on the morning
commute free pandemic
also face coverings i would say at least
80 percent of people that we've seen
passing through the station and on the
trains here this morning
still wearing face coverings the
stations staff are the train drivers are
i asked one woman who got off a train
why she was wearing a mask and she said
there had actually been tallow
announcements during the journey asking
people
to keep their face covering on we know
in london of course transport for london
making it a condition of carriage
here in the west midlands the mayor said
he would expect people to still wear
masks on public transport
out of respect to staff under vulnerable
passengers so actually
to be honest it doesn't feel that much
different than it would have done on
friday here
what about where you are paul is the
pandemic doing um its damage there
uh it does feel a little bit like a
slightly different picture to birmingham
this is uh
in oxfordshire it's on the west coast
main line into london so a busy commuter
route
there's a six-story multi-storey car
park
here okay for commuters to park in there
are 13 cars in it this morning and one
of them is mine that gives you an idea
of the nature of the return to work it's
a pretty funny freedom isn't it that
celebrates a return to commuter trains
and people just aren't coming back in
any kind of
numbers compared to back in march last
year i'd echo what becky said
face coverings 80 at least to people
i've seen
wearing masks i'm only not wearing mine
so that you can hear me a little more
clearly
gwr who run these trains say they expect
customers to passengers to wear them out
of respect
for uh fellow travellers but there's no
mandating of them but you wouldn't know
it from around the station all the
signage still talks
about masks we'll wait and see what it's
like when we get into central london
where there is no
expectation that there will be a rush
back to work just because the government
has removed the advice to work from home
okay uh thanks but interesting pool to
see the guy behind you
um didn't have his mask on just about to
get on the train and has decided to put
it on i'm sure that's what a lot of
passengers will be doing thank you both
appreciate it
we're also hearing uh from the minister
weren't we just in the last few minutes
he said he is going to be
wearing his mask in enclosed spaces also
making news
for you this morning officials in
siberia say wildfires there have grown
by nearly a quarter of a million acres
in the last 24 hours
they've warned the region is
experiencing its driest summer for 150
years
more than 2 000 firefighters have now
been brought in to help
fight the blaze
three people have died during
yesterday's hot weather across the uk
great manchester police recovered the
body of a teenager from salford keys a
man in his 50s died
in the river oohs near york while a
teenage girl died in water near whitney
in oxfordshire
government ministers in australia say
they're deporting the controversial
british commentator katie hopkins
after she bragged about breaking
quarantine restrictions
hopkins was due to take part in a
reality tv show when she boasted on
social media
about meeting hotel staff which is
against the rules
the australian border force acted very
quickly to make sure that uh the visa on
which she entered
uh was cancelled so there was obviously
a bit of a process that
we needed to follow with that we will be
getting her
um out of the country as soon as we can
possibly uh
arrange that so i'm hopeful that that
will happen imminently
in other news the german government has
pledged nearly 250 million pounds to
help flood victims
a massive cleanup operation is underway
right across germany belgium
and the netherlands this morning our
europe correspondent adam parsons
is in germany for us today hello to you
adam um looking behind you
i mean i've covered many floods here in
the uk nothing to that level
of devastation how are people coping
well this is availa in western germany
and you arrive here and the first thing
that hits you is almost a smell
and you work it out it's like being in a
seaside town but of course it's the
smell
of mud everywhere you look in this
ruined town there is mud around you
and you and signs of the ferocity of
these floods look at this sign
this has been bent completely out of
shape by the power
of the water this deep mud here but i
want to show you something
that i think brings home just how
devastating this
was that mark up there way way above my
head that is where the water
reached up to just imagine that
flood coming through here and sweeping
everything
in its path look at this this is a very
very hefty bit of a bit of metal
furniture and that has simply been
thrown down the street and here's
another
example of the ferocity of nature here
this uh estate car every window is
smashed
the car in front of it look through the
back window there just look at the mud
that has been piled
into that well the german government
yeah is talking about supply hundreds of
millions of euros let's be frank it's
going to cost a lot
lot more than that to repair all this
damage angela merkel was
just down the road yesterday talking
about the need to develop a plan
imminently at the moment the german
people i think support that but they
will want action
fast okay adam for now thank you
of course we'll update you throughout
the course of the day and what's
happening in germany weather extremes
sunshine here in the uk nas is standing
by hottest day of the year so far
yesterday i believe now's what's planned
for today
it's still remaining hot okay this week
we're going to continue with the heat
some areas have already met their heat
wave criteria
so the heat wave continues for some
spots as well
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it was a hot and sunny
weekend for many
areas and the heat continues for this
week as well
as well as some very warm oppressive
nights to come in fact
it was a warm muggy night for many areas
and it looks like the isle of portland
in devon
stayed above 20 degrees celsius making
it officially a tropical night
there so warm muggy bright mornings some
murky conditions around northern and
eastern parts so where it's cooler with
some drizzle across northern scotland
most that burns back towards coastal
areas
where the north and east coasts of the
uk will stay quite cool
and it's not as warm across parts of
scotland northern england but another
hot
day elsewhere
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
so remember your sunscreen if you are
going out today and also be really
really careful in open water
three people lost their lives in the uk
yesterday
um do take care of your out and about
let me show you these pictures two
syrian bears that were rescued from a
zoo
in southern lebanon are being relocated
to the united states after being kept in
a cage
for a decade you've got to be kidding me
homer and ulysses
will be able to walk freely and on grass
for the first time
in 10 years they'll fly from the lebanon
to america
where they'll go to a new permanent home
in a wildlife sanctuary
in chicago they have no idea what is
coming but
they most certainly deserve a decade in
that cage
why do people do that now lockdown is
easing in england but how worried
should we be about the spread of
coronavirus we'll talk to dr
david nabarro from the world health
organization that's next
[Music]
i'm greg milam skye's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
i've seen the dark side of america
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we are at a breaking point and we need
to work
now and fast even though young people
are vulnerable
to the input of climate change young
people can also become the change agents
that we need to address
the climate impact in my campaign or in
advocacy work i work
largely with young people so that their
voices can be heard so they can also
influence
decision making from the local level to
the national level and thankfully
we are making progress in a regard
[Music]
and again the government says a final
decision will be taken today on whether
to give covert vaccines to under-18s
the united states and many european
nations have already started offering
the jab
to teenagers short while ago the
vaccine's minister nadine zahawi
tell me he will make an announcement in
parliament this afternoon
so the joint committee on vaccination
and immunization
have just delivered their advice we'll
consider it in fact
uh after my morning round uh we have a
oh and then i will make a statement to
parliament
but uh suffice to say they've looked
very closely especially at children
who are more vulnerable to serious
affection from covert
children who live with adults who are
more vulnerable serious infection from
covert and of course
17 year olds who are close to becoming
18 so three months from the 18th
birthday
and we will take that advice on board
and i'll make a statement to parliament
later today
tomorrow's here um jabs for kids then
that's right it's going ahead today and
nadim zahawi
confirmed but we understand that what
the government is going to recommend
is not jabs for all children over 12 as
they are doing in the u.s and israel and
france and malta
but only those who are vulnerable or
about to turn
18. now why that matters is because
professor neil ferguson who obviously
did all the modeling which led to the
first lockdown
says if we're going to reach herd
immunity the level of immunity we need
to see the virus
start to decline then that means we'll
have to vaccinate
teenagers in a big way so question about
whether if you don't do that given
that the levels of transmission among
young people and teenagers
are very high at the moment whether
we're going to be able to get a grip
on the virus this year but nadim zahar
we said that one thing that the
scientists
on jcbi are concerned about is a very
rare heart condition called myocarditis
so we may hear more about that in
parliament later okay and a quick
thought on masks
masks yes suddenly the government now
think that tfl's policy
of having masks is great we've gone from
we can't wait to throw them off till we
recommend you wearing them to now
wearing them
is great and that just shows really how
spooked they have been by
the huge rising cases we've seen and
predictions yesterday
that we could see not just a hundred
thousand but two hundred thousand cases
by the end of the summer and potentially
over a thousand
up to two thousand hospitalizations
ministers have never said
what level of hospitalizations would
threaten to overwhelm the health service
because obviously
it depends where they are geographically
and whether some areas are more
effective than others
but certainly i think the whole the
rhetoric of freedom day and the
irreversible route house of lockdown
seems to have fallen by the wayside at
least for now for now thank you very
much indeed tomorrow thanks so we've
been chatting to our teams up and down
the country uh
at railway stations and they're telling
us that around about anecdotally about
80 percent of people who are traveling
on trains today at least
are wearing their masks what will you do
uh perhaps you'd like to tweet us and
let us know
at k burley uh lockdown restrictions
might be easy in england then but
scientists are remaining concerned about
the spread
of covid19 there have been more than 48
000 new cases in the latest
24-hour period joined now by the world
health organization's special envoy on
kovid19 dr david
nabarro a friend of the program hello to
doctor always great to see you
you think the government's doing this
too early don't you why
well i'm i want to be really clear with
you k
of course at some point uh as
as ministers have said we have to get on
and get our lives going again it's just
what's our attitude while we're doing it
and so
your summary just now of of where we
stand
seems to me to be really important there
is
no sense of freedom in my heart
unfortunately there's a sense that this
virus is very much
here and is giving us lots of surprises
lots of anxieties and therefore as a
society
we go into the next period with our eyes
wide open knowing pretty well what to
expect
that is more disease more long covered
and more challenges as to as to how we
actually behave
my recommendation is simply wear your
mask
don't get too close to people watch out
in confined spaces
and remember this virus hasn't gone away
if you're asked to isolate please
isolate
and just let's get through the next two
or three months
with the minimum possible damage and at
the same time working out
how to get on with our lives despite the
presence of this virus
you say um if you're pinged then you
should self-isolate but i'm sure you've
seen the figures doctor 1.7 million
people in the united kingdom
are self-isolating at the moment they're
having to change the rules for nhs staff
otherwise our hospitals will be
overwhelmed there
isn't enough food on supermarket shelves
at what stage do we have to say
we people do need to go to work
well i think actually people are going
to have to go to work now
i accept all that and that some measure
of
rethinking all these issues like
self-isolation is obviously happening
right now
look at the debate that happened
yesterday around the contacts
of uh the health secretary so what i'd
like to suggest to everybody is
anticipate strong and consistent
messages from government
and others in the next few weeks i think
everybody throughout the world is
is coming to terms with what this virus
means
it's not a case of just saying we've had
enough we're going to get go back to
normal
we've actually got to together uh
establish
what the new normal is like and and i
think there will be a good new normal
for all of us we'll be able to connect
together and get on with our lives
but we for the time being at least while
a lot of us are still to be vaccinated
we've got to do everything possible to
to
reduce the rate of build-up of this
virus and be ready for
new variants coming along because that
will be a big challenge for the
months to come yeah do so are you saying
the covert 19 app needs to be looked at
and tweaked or not is that what you're
saying
well i'm i'm going to say the government
will need to consider
how to deal with the people being
requested to isolate and there are
options on the table
uh what what matters and and it was
clear from uh announcements over the
weekend
what matters is that this is done quite
quickly and in a clear and unequivocal
way
so that everybody everywhere knows what
to do i think that that
is the hardest part of of moving from a
period of restrictions to a release
is that uh everybody needs to be
absolutely clear in their own minds
what what they may do and what they may
not do and
it's that consistency of guidance that's
going to be
really critical not just in the uk but
but everywhere
it's actually throughout the world now
yeah my i we're out of time but my
viewers would be furious if you didn't
ask how your grandson is
well i saw them on skype over the
weekend
absolutely brilliant sort of strong and
together but gosh i'm missing missing
them and there's one as you know i
haven't seen
but uh with the new new uh constraints
coming in
it may be still more time before we can
meet isn't it
challenging just wanting to get on with
the normal things of being together and
this virus just keeps making life
difficult for us all
hopefully soon doctor it's always great
to see you thanks for taking the time
thank you thank you thanks very much
thank you
care homes have suffered more than most
during the pandemic
in england more than 40 000 residents
have died from covid19 and homes have
been
under strict lockdown from today however
limits on visitor numbers
have been lifted joined now by steve
dorrington he is the owner and
operator of dorington house care homes
in norfolk hello to you thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
um what changes will you see as a result
of these restrictions being eased
well i agree with some of the speakers
that i've heard already
and um we're preceding the caution i'm
pleased for the families no one's
mentioned that
um the chat jeremy from four seasons
he was saying it's sort of steady as you
go testing
uh we're maintaining hygiene and we're
still wearing the mask for the time
being
and we're watching with uh baited breath
and
what do you want uh people that are
coming to visit whether it's loved ones
or others
to see your residents what are the rules
for them do they still need to wear
masks
uh yes they do and they're tested as
well
and if not they email us with proof of
being tested
negative if not we we will do lecture
testing anyway
when they come in through the door and
uh what is interesting we've got three
homes one is at whatton
the other end of the high street is a
meat processing factory which had 350
cases
and because we had the vaccine before
christmas due to a pilot scheme by the
surgery we were ahead of the game there
and we had no
um virus there at all but at the other
two homes we did dirham and
wales next to sea and what's further
interesting is
we have had three staff that uh walton
um
youngsters who we can't control when
they're at home
out of our site and um they uh
they tested uh positive they weren't
unwell
we're testing all the staff and the
residents they're all negative
and those three members start and they
back negative as well
steve how worried are you about your
residence
being affected even though they've
they've had two vaccinations and
potentially a booster in september
that they could still be caught up in
the next wave
of this virus we've seen the health
secretary of course he's had uh two
vaccinations and he still contracted the
disease yeah
yeah um yeah that's that's fact if
you've got
if you've had two jabs that doesn't uh
exonerate you from an infection
uh we're very careful we're getting a
lot of requests for
respect here we're very diligent with
the hospitals
and they are quite cooperative now
everybody's learning
and we are insisting that they are clear
when they come into the home and
the residents themselves uh those that
with capacity they are understanding and
so are the families they've been quite
cooperative
there have been some um you know
altercations with families not very many
and we still have got staff that won't
be vaccinated which is a problem
uh but i'll ask you about that right
yeah i wanted to ask you about that
because uh there is a suggestion that um
staff should
it should be mandatory for them to be
vaccinated what do you think
well um personally myself and my family
have had it and i'm all in favor of
vaccination
and i have tried to persuade staff
there's various reasons as we don't want
to go all over again
you know culture uh fertility
and um they're they're well they're
made well aware of it and i'm watching
those in particular
with uh because we're kobe tests when
they come back i see them all
and i'm monitoring that they're negative
but
um i i don't know how we're gonna
enforce it by law we've got basically
until
february if you include the 16 weeks if
we still
have a big issue with a hundred thousand
cases
plus plus and hospital admissions going
up
then maybe um the government will have
to get tougher with the population
because there are still a lot of
people out there that won't have to chat
and do you feel
uh as far as your homes are concerned
are care workers that it should be
mandatory
if they won't do it themselves uh yes
um human rights if you want to go on
holiday to some countries you have to
have various vaccinations
if you're a gp or a doctor in the
hospitals
you have to have various vaccinations as
part of your job
but um it's a bit like um jumping on the
last
dinosaur egg you know if we start
picking and choosing who we employ
um there's not gonna be anyone left okay
it's good to talk to you
this morning thank you so much for
joining us uh this morning thanks a lot
keep on caring uh absolutely uh we heard
from
the uh vaccines minister earlier on
today find out what he had to say about
wearing masks about children
being jabbed and what he thinks about
prince charles not wanting to wear his
mask all of that to come very shortly
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
warm spells of sunshine will develop
across most of the uk and ireland today
and it'll be very warm or hot again
across many central and southern areas
however scotland and northern england
won't be as warm and it'll be cloudy and
cool with some drizzle over northern and
eastern coastal counties
polo levels will be high for most areas
today except across
northern scotland where they will be
moderate we are now in the peak of the
grass and weed pollen season
and fungal spores are at their peak too
the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
freedom day how you feeling about it
well nightclubs have been closed longer
than almost
all businesses during the lockdown but
at midnight
last night the doors reopened in england
with no masks
or social distancing a warning that this
report from
jemima walker does contain flashing
images
the moment they've been waiting for
[Music]
this the first few seconds of july the
19th
egg in london was one of the first
nightclubs to close
now
i'm really excited yeah it's just um
obviously it's been
such a long time and i just want to get
on the dance floor
i just feel like it's a good experience
to have night clubs again
i feel like i've been robbed for the 19
year olds here it's their first time
inside a nightclub
it just feels like we haven't lived the
last year and a half
yeah like all of the people older than
us have told us you know our whole lives
about going clubbing and
dancing and growing up in that way and
we haven't had that
um so we're about to have it finally
feel our age you know what i mean
for parts of the nighttime economy
getting to this point has been no mean
feat charlie jilks owns 11 nighttime
venues
pinging has been a complete and utter
nightmare and it's almost
locked down by the back door three of
our venues had to close for 10 days
the government now advises nightclubs to
ask for proof of double vaccination
or a negative test but it's not
mandatory
and there are questions about the
practicalities that was brought up very
late in the day
uh by the government um you know by
which time
we'd already taken all of our bookings i
think it's
you know at the moment it's impractical
because you know most of our clean
up clientele are under the age of 30.
they haven't had their second jab yet
i think a lot of people go to a
nightclub as a spontaneous thing
some of course feel it's too soon to be
rubbing shoulders with strangers on a
dance floor
but for many this day has been a very
long time coming
jemima walker sky news
i have to say on my way to work this
morning there were an awful lot of very
relaxed
people looking for cabs in central
london let's speak to the chief exec of
city pub group and that's clive
watson hello to clive thanks for joining
us on the programme this morning how are
you feeling about restrictions being
lifted
mix mix mixed emotions to be honest uh i
think
it's great that for instance nightclubs
can reopen
but you know having
staff being told that they don't have to
wear masks
i don't think it's a good thing and and
we're actually going to tell our staff
that
encourage yourself very much to white
mars and carry on with a lot of the
safety measures that we've already got
in place uh at the moment so
it's mixed emotions what about your
customers what uh what
do you want them to do what precautions
do they need to take
i think i just want our customers to
respect uh our staff i wanted to come
into the pub
and not have a free-for-all i want them
to go to the table
order their food and drinks either on
our city club app
or a wait for table service not to have
a big scrum at the bar
not to abuse staff if they're wearing
masks
just just to respect everyone inside
that building
uh because at the end of the day what
we're trying to achieve is
uh you know the safety for customers and
staff
alike do you want your customers to wear
masks
uh no that's impractical because
obviously they'll be eating and drinking
but
moving around yeah
yeah definitely i'd encourage it i'm not
going to enforce it
but encourage it and i said it comes
down to respect
and if people don't like customers they
like the idea
of our staff whatever uh wearing masks
then you know
it's just to go somewhere else this is
about the welfare
of everyone inside the bill the um
prime minister had heralded this day
19th of july as a big
freedom day and all the shackles of
covid19 would be tossed
to one side speaking to my guest this
morning i'm not getting that
impression at all people are still very
cautious very concerned about what else
this virus might be able to do to us as
a nation
yeah when he set the freedom day
whenever it was four
four months ago obviously we thought
we'd be in a better place than we are at
the moment
um but we're now cases of rising as we
all know
and yes that that rising cases creates
more caution
more concern so yes as i said as mixed
emotions
is today is the day of celebration in
some ways it is because festivals and
nightclubs can open
but it'd be much better if some of the
safety measures
were still government regulated than
self-regulated by
different venues and you still want
people to use the um covered app do you
to check into the pub
so um if they're pinged the everybody
else in the pub will have to
self-isolate how are you feeling about
that
well we're going through that at the
moment so um
you know that's that's you know a third
of our pubs have been affected by
um the things we've just talked about
and we're getting lots of cancellations
from customers and
particularly in group bookings where
some of them uh
pinged or actually got the virus so you
know that's just something we've learned
to live with
uh before and gonna have to learn to
live with until this pandemics find us
and are you chilled with people coming
to order at the bar or do you still want
um
table service basically um what happened
yesterday
you still want that to be in place today
definitely definitely i mean we're not
going to be militant and say you can't
come to the bar
but we're going to have people in front
of our pubs as they come in
guided towards tables encouraged to use
the app
uh to encourage to wait for table
service we do not want
a whole lot of people charging the bar
and you know three deep at the bar and
that's only going to you know increase
the number of infections
and also as i said compromise uh the
safety of our staff
okay clive um good to talk to you thanks
for joining us this morning appreciate
thanks it much thanks a lot quick look
at what's happening with the weather
it's going to be another scorcher
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it was hot and sunny across
many parts of the uk island over the
weekend and the heat
continues for this week as well in fact
it moves further northwards across
northern areas
yesterday it wasn't as warm and it won't
be as warm for today but eventually that
heat will reach parts of the north where
it will be hotting up as well
it's been a warm and muggy night as well
a bright start for many areas but some
northern and eastern parts
a rather cloudy murky cool start for
this morning but the murky conditions
and the low cloud burning back towards
coastal counties of the north and east
where it remains cooler throughout today
across northern parts of scotland cloudy
with some patchy drizzle
elsewhere though lots of sunshine
developing yet again
another very warm or hot day
particularly across central and southern
areas
temperatures will be hovering around 30
to 31 degrees
celsius not as warm for inland parts of
northern ireland northern england
scotland but still a fine day there and
largely dry
the weather sponsored by qatar airways